We'll take that first hand and we'll
take the idea of transferring
uh from the arm to his body. Okay.
So, we can add the push now. But I still
am controlling what happens there.
Okay, try
Hold
this as far as you get.
and change. Okay.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Heat.
And we'll just be adding detail
progressively as we go. Okay. So, watch
first the orientation. 12 six and
where's the throw go
together 90
makes no sense you go right back in
north to ten con and you're back on a 12
six line. So you'll rotate the the five
the two
back to the 45. Okay. Trust
I mean, right.
[Music]
Not harder. Not harder to throw than
harder to get this
That's a lot.
Now bring this one. Remember the is
pushing is pushing. Still adhering on.
[Music]
Okay, next detail.
Remember not to stress
the grip.
So, one set does its job. That's it. The
rest is all my I I work inside the grip,
not pulling him cuz I'm going to
transfer control to his body.
Don't pull this.
And I'm not going to try to drop his
corner.
This I'm going to enter into the space.
You'll have to look for it. He can
always feel it.
But I'm going here.
So this cushy here is on here.
I don't pull on my grip.
[Music]
Okay, try
Bring your awareness to the pressure,
the grip when you're throwing. You
should feel none.
[Music]
Can you see? Can you feel it on your
leg? Okay. But there's no tripping.
Can you see it?
Okay.
Do you really need the
actual 45? No, but I just need to go 90
to the to his line. Okay. So, I did this
variation.
Well, I got to go over there now. There
it is.
You do the quick variation.
It's right there.
Okay.
Try it again.
Get off the arm.
[Music]
Go to the yin space. Where's the room?
I know it's weird and you know it's
weird because
one of the things that we do in modern
Iikido is we protect ourselves, right?
We protect ourselves. You know what I'm
talking about? Like protect yourselves.
Okay? But in there is our
wanting of control.
Um so
we go
and then I'm I'm already going down. You
see that? I'm going through me. So,
watch watch your uh your knee to like
try to get into this. What'll happen
then is you're just going to trip up on
that foot, which partially that's what
stops you from trying to get your feet
back underneath. You get it?
But
what what you can do is just experience
this work
and I can help you down.
here. Don't go that way. You got to go
that way.
There is where my hand is.
Well, that would have stopped me. All
right.
Okay, try it.
Y
you're using the arms too much. You
shouldn't feel anything in the arms.
Let yourself fall
with your arms.
[Music]
Where's your weight go? Mid foot.
Where's their yong aspect? Go mid foot.
Off your heels.
Don't pull them around. Don't pull them
around.
Better.
Leave your arms.
I don't I don't care if you if you gain
it right now. Okay. So, I don't I don't
care.
Get that angle. Don't do this. Don't do
this. This is This is where I'm going.
Okay. Good.
Experiment
displacement.
It's good.
Now leave the rudder ring on. Okay. Game
however you want. So you can put that
foot wherever you want right now. Okay.
If you're out like this, then you're
going to have to move it. Yeah. So
remember in the technique, your left
foot goes where you need it to go for
this part.
And I'm going to go in here.
Okay.
Okay, try
[Music]
and pull them across your leg.
Don't use the Don't use the ice.
Heel weighted. Get on the midway.
Don't use your arms.
Don't pull them across.
partner.
Again, don't do anything. Okay, we're
not we don't have the top part in the
technique, right? So, we're not really
generating the tossy turn effect, but
your base is being pushed out. So, the
fall is only from this high. Okay?
No, no one's being flipped up in the air
and topsy turby. Okay, risk it.
[Music]
Pull it across.
Doesn't matter what path is. This is
what I'm working.
Just don't use it. You're not You're on
the body now, not the arm.
[Music]
Right into his thigh.
And you let don't let your weight go to
the heels. Ground it to the mid foot
with one
step. Don't move the back foot. That's
grounding.
That's fine. That's it. Right.
Heel weight.
Yep. That's it.
Remember, don't do tension. Don't do
sum. Do this base displacement. Yep.
No.
Yeah. No.
Yeah.
[Music]
Don't use the arm.
So, I'll tell you what. So,
when when you use the arm,
that means that you injured. Just relax.
That means that you injured.
It's not loaded. Then you load it here.
You see that?
But that should have already been your
That's your angle attack. has to throw.
Boom. When the base comes in. Okay.
Relax. Relax.
So, don't hit the arm. Try and do it
just like this.
To me, the mechanics are the same. I
ground this foot. His weight. I keep
grounding on that foot.
Okay, let's do that. See what happens.
Leave your rear foot where it is on the
ground.
Yes, that's it.
[Music]
Yep, that's it. There's no there's no
way he should fall exactly like in the
technique because I don't have his
forward inertia. I don't have the
centipal energy. You understand? So
don't expect the same result. It's just
did I get
to displace him where he is in space?
Okay, that's what I'm doing.
Okay. What would be incorrect?
Miss. Okay. Not deep enough.
Not grounded enough.
So we're just here. Sh.
Okay. Try.
Don't shuffle that foot in behind you.
Leave it on the ground.
[Music]
Yes.
what we've been doing the whole time.
Your weight goes in this case is on the
back foot.
That's where my weight goes. His
resistance goes on the back foot, too.
This This is how much penetration I can
do on my body.
So that means that foot has to be close
enough where when I finish here, this
Koshi had displaced his Koshi. Does that
make sense?
You don't want to go here
cuz you ungrounded the back foot. Okay.
Try it again. Put that outside foot
wherever you need it to be for the range
of your body, for the task at hand.
mid foot. There's no f there's no
falling here in this dojo. There's no
falling. There's no catching balance.
Little baby steps. That's all. I didn't
let the energy pass through me to the
ground on the back foot. Okay.
Getting healing.
No, we're not doing the bump. I get to
just see Deiani.
Watch your heel weight.
No.
Yes.
Watch the back foot. Don't let it move
again.
Yep.
It's not It doesn't have to be big. I
know the effect looks big on the UK, but
if I have to make a big move, it's not
going to be Marshall. It's a very tiny
move. Okay? So, don't try to get the big
reaction. Just do the task.
Ground. Left foot. Stay grounded. There
comes more y'all. Ground left foot.
Okay, let's go.
Don't shuffle in again.
Don't shuffle in. Don't bring that back
foot with you.
That's it. But we got heel weight.
Use your shoulder.
Good.
Good. Good. Good.
Watch how much you're leaning forward
cuz it has to be mid foot back.
That's it.
Watch the back foot.
Don't Don't bump. Don't bump. Keep keep.
So if I if I'm lying on my weight on the
back foot and I do that, then some of my
weight's over here. You see that? So
that's why we we don't bump. I know you
want to bump, but we don't bump. You
don't want to go here like this.
Okay. You're just you're just moving
through.
Just moving through.
Yes. Ground the back foot.
Good. Ground the back foot. Your weight.
Their weight. Back foot. Kersel.
You went too far around the back.
[Music]
Okay.
Careful. You want to do
You got to do it with your foot.
If you can't put your foot there and
bend your hip,
you'll move as a unit.
Watch the back foot
to desire.
your foot.
Put your foot there and then make
contact.
Okay.
So, I'm here there.
The yin space is behind, right? Okay.
So, I got to step down. This is space,
but I got to touch the cushion. Okay. So
you're going to go right behind her so
that this can touch. So I'm going to do
what I'm telling you not to do. You can
see it's in alignment. Okay. Now the
engine for it
isn't me moving her this way.
The engine is not me bumping her. The
engine is on the ad.
Okay. There's no that and my foot's not
there first and then I go. Okay. And I
don't pull them. I'll do it. You would
have positioned them already. That's
telling you where to step. There's no
more need to pull on them. Okay. So, in
this drill, maybe you get on the bridge
and on that line.
I'm going to go right behind that
and displace. Okay. Try it.
Just stand with your feet together.
We'll simplify it even more in case
you're in time.
Now, don't expect a lot, but don't don't
be tempted to shuffle in that back foot.
Better
crap. Oh, shuffling in.
Double shuffle in.
That's good.
Okay.
Two angle jump.
Don't you don't pay attention to your
hip.
Hey, couple other
there
you have to just as in the technique
this foot is measured for the task and
my natural length of stance.
So too is the angle of attack.
So if I step this foot out that way and
this foot goes in,
I'm heel weight. Okay. So to demonstrate
this, this is why I say between your two
feet,
the maximum that they can go is 90° to
each other.
If you pay attention to me,
the front foot is turned this way and
the back foot is turned this way. Okay,
does that make sense? Okay, so to
demonstrate how our weight will shift
as our toes are pointed away from each
other,
you'll just stand like this
and point your toes even more.
Okay, just to feel that. And if you can
after you get pushed, I want you to turn
your feet out and then let release. Let
all tension go. And on your own, you
should have felt it. But the reason
we're staying upright when my feet are
away is why tension is holding you in
place. But if you take your feet out and
you release, you're going to immediately
fall backwards. Okay? So, two discovery
learnings. I'll let you kind of resist
so you feel the tension in your body to
hold the position. And we'll just go
cushion. Okay. Now, you're going to
release.
And I don't care who you are. It's just
physics. It's just architecture.
If you're able to stay standing and
release, you didn't release. You have
that tension in you. Okay? See if you
can feel it. You might not be able to
because you still have it unconscious
tension. Feel
your urge to flex
and then try and release on your own.
Okay. So, for this reason,
uh, as you're going and you're trying
this drill,
his mass is now amplifying how much
weight on my face. That's what makes me
leak energy out the back of my heels.
Okay? So, I can't do that.
You can see my feet are here. You could
have done that. I tend not to do that.
Okay? So,
be cognizant. At least when I tell you
you're heel weighted, your feet are
pointing away from each other. Okay? I
tell you, your feet are pointed away
from each other, your heel weight. But
play with it. Turn that front foot in
more. Make sure that this doesn't open
on you.
The reason why it opens is because when
you drag it
cuz you moved it, it now opens on you.
And now my feet are pointing away from
the angle that you need for the attack
here. Okay.
Try not to guard. There you go.
Yep.
Keep your back straight. Keep your spine
extending.
Straight to me doesn't mean straight up
and down. It means your spine is
extending like in Zazen.
Watch it drive. Don't drag it.
Good. Shift your weight onto the front
foot. It's 60/40 stance.
Your foot is there first
which is not correct. Just move as a
unit.
Better up heel weight.
Good.
Your foot is
your foot.
That's it.
Your foot is going
fine tuning the contact point your
on your body
here. foot here on their body here.
Okay, I got
Resist
the bump. Just move as a unit.
Good.
Foot weight. Quick weight. Not in front
of my toes, not behind my heels.
Don't shuffle the back foot or it'll
drag. It'll turn out and you'll heal
weighted.
Good.
Okay. Next detail.
Don't use bear bears with gravity. You
come around here and you're up.
You see that
on this side.
So don't let your foot come up and then
do it.
Your your foot is sliding.
Foot is sliding.
But it's
accomplishing the same thing with the
displacement, but not by the same means.
Okay,
the means I want is my grounding foot
there. You might have your foot up and
still ground.
Okay. But you notice he's moving before
the foot is set. On the other one, it is
force. My mouse is forced,
but we're moving here.
Okay.
Try to keep your foot as low as
possible.
Get your weight onto the front leg.
Front leg.
There you go.
Just like my that step would be so
unnatural for me, but this short step is
natural for you. Okay.
Watch the hip bumping
too much angle.
You can just go there. You can just go
there.
Okay. So, we did um we we pointed out
that when I am going to poke you, I've
always poke through you through the
center. I can't poke you in front of the
center. There still is a range aspect.
There's still an angle of attack aspect.
So, I can't hit around the corner,
right? I can't aim in front. So, for
those that weren't here,
okay? And we were doing it on this
elbow. And I can't be in front of him.
It has to get to the center.
Likewise, I'm going around the center.
You see? So, there's an angle of attack.
So, when he's standing there, you have
to be careful because think about why we
did that in the first place because that
is where he's the lightest. He's the
heaviest at the center. See? So, he's
the lightest around the center on the
periphery. Okay? So that's where this
angle is coming from instead of this
angle is you're like
and but now the impact on the center is
less. Okay. And an exaggeration would be
this. Okay. So you got to watch that.
You're like I'm shave some off. You
missed. It's right through here.
Okay. And why can't you do that? Because
his young aspect is just going there. is
just making my foot heavier. Okay, try
it again. Don't miss the center.
Don't drag the foot.
Don't drag the foot. It makes your feet
go out.
The back foot. Leave it where it is.
Don't overiner so that it pulls that
back foot.
Better. Yes.
Lock your upper body just like saus.
Keep wanting to put the foot.
The engine is the left foot, not the
right foot. No. Behind your foot there.
Every once in a while
you're
you're over here and you put the foot
over there. You stay here and now you're
using both legs.
You don't want to do that.
I like this. This is what I'm driving.
So if he's driving at me, I'm grounding
on this foot. You understand? And that
is what moves.
So as my foot moves,
my center is moving as opposed to my
center stay. The foot move, then my
center move. You see that? Okay. So
don't sneak that foot in there.
roundness this place. Okay,
that means your center has to move
moves first.
You went around
your spine.
Okay. Mid foot weight. Stay midoot
weighted.
Watch the gravity. All right.
Watch the driving.
If you want that extra range, just put
that foot closer. Okay. When you first
start.
Good. Good. Good. Good. Good. And watch
how your feet don't turn out from each
other. So, where you put that foot, if
you put it with it already out, you're
already going to start breaking that
rule. So, maybe just put it straight.
Put it straight and then go in. Okay.
Try it.
how you want to go around it. We're not
going around right now. Okay, we're
going through
Thank you very much.
Be mid-foot weight. Don't go heel
weight. Even if he falls, it doesn't
matter. You want to be mid-foot weight.
midfoot weight. Make sure you're midoot
weight.
Breathe out and relax.
You put a letter. You get my
Okay.
in the technique. He doesn't have his
mass here.
His mass is back here, right? And
there's a pull from the inertia on the
center. We're not going to work with the
inertia, but we'll take some mass off of
the legs. Got it? Not not a lot, just a
little.
And we do the same thing. But what
you're going to notice is that it got a
lot lighter. A lot lighter with that
little tiny tilt. Okay? If you lose your
balance, take the fall, but nothing's
really on top controlling that top part
of the lever. Okay? So, watch, please.
That was it. You'll see how much lighter
he gets.
Okay.
Um I've said many times
in for Nagia
that's all you need. That's it. We don't
need that or all the other gymnastics.
People don't do that in the street. They
don't do that. Okay. They try to stay
upright. You get that. That's all you
need. It's too late. Okay. So, I was
here and you saw all I did was that.
Okay. And then notice how light that is
now. Okay, try it.
You got to keep the same
your back foot.
Watch your foot angle. Put back here.
Yep.
Yep. Watch out. We don't want to bounce
off. We don't want to fall. We're not
going to be down, guys. Step all over
the place. Ground the back foot.
Make sure the foot doesn't go toward the
center.
And don't let it dry again. Don't let
the toes point away from each other.
You're leaning too far forward.
Don't bump the hip.
The foot went first.
Lock your body. Lock your upper body.
It's two. Okay.
[Music]
Watch the desire
better. Yes.
Cast yourself with mid foot.
No hip bump.
Yes.
Now hip f
Okay,
take him into that little tiny bend
and
try to push here.
You don't do anything. Neither resist
nor assist. And you'll see.
Okay. I want you to feel that like
that's too much. That's more than the
two counts I always want to feel. Okay.
He's not he's not doing anything like
that. But he I can feel that it's not
going to be arm weight anymore that
takes this. Ah that I'm pushing now.
Okay. So just discovery learning on
that. Go.
You're just on the side. You haven't
entered. Do not enter. They start with a
tilt and then you try to just slowly
push. You'll see you're starting to t
tense more.
It doesn't matter whether they go back
or not. You're measuring. I had to push
one.
Don't turn them back.
Okay, next discovery.
I'm going to displace and try
the same thing. He might fall, he might
not fall. Doesn't matter. If he falls,
he keeps his head off the mat. Okay. So,
we start with the tilt, my hand is
resting.
And you'll see as the center comes up,
the legs come up, the top gets very
light. I don't push past the original
lightness. I attack the base and I
follow that same lightness pressure
down. Okay.
Is it visible? No. Can you see it? Can
you feel it? Okay. Try it.
Your own arm weight will do it.
Put your arm across his body.
Displace.
Don't trip. Displace
your foot. First
still displace the base.
Good.
Change first.
Too much arm.
Displace the top gets light.
The top gets
My shot
more displacement.
Yeah.
Work on your foot angle. Foot vectoring.
Don't use any arm strength. Just let the
weight do it.
[Music]
Don't trip.
Go through the center.
It around it.
You're too sharp. Two that way. Not
enough in the center.
[Music]
Got to attack center with the base
first.
center has to move.
So Kushi
for me like break his balance. Okay.
What what is that? What does that mean?
It means that his line of gravity has to
fall outside his face.
The line of gravity, the top of the line
of gravity is the center of gravity.
Center of gravity is where he's the
heaviest. That's his mass. Okay.
Um
when the guy leans back,
all that happened in this drill is what?
center
line of gravity.
It moves up. It drops. It goes up.
Does everyone understand that?
So here's a person
and the center of gravity on a normal
human being is we're taught in somewhere
around
understand it's not on the surface of
your skin inside but towards the front
of the spine. Okay, so it's somewhere
around here.
The line of gravity
is always
perpendicular
between the center of gravity and in
this case the back. Okay, so he is
balanced right now which is why when you
release you don't fall.
If you lean backwards,
the center of gravity is coming this
way.
Your heels about here.
You're just outside.
Got it? Which is why when you release
tension, everything just falls to the
back. Are you with me? Okay.
As the guy
leans backwards,
that center of gravity
is going to move this way to the back
and I'm sorry the line of gravity is
going to move this way which inversely
means that the center of gravity came up
now it's further back okay
then
is
I'm going to define it in a reverse
fashion.
The line of gravity
has to be taken outside the base of
support.
If I if you bend me like I was we had
the video of
Ta
and I said do try to push it. You've
given me a wider base. Now base support
is my contact with the mat and the area
shaded in between. One, two, three. this
whole triangle
the center of gravity somewhere around
here deeper into a wider base that's why
you can't push okay
did anyone try that experiment okay
usually what happens is the behavioral
cue goes and the person lets you go okay
so let's run the experiment
um
you're just here
you're the nugget All
right.
There we go. And I'm there like this.
And then depending on the system,
sometimes he shuffles forward and you
take the ball.
Sometimes he moves forward with this
foot and you take the ball. You
understand? Okay. Um, let's do that
first.
Go ahead and take the ball. Take the
ball. Let yourself go.
Let yourself
let yourself
Now,
don't let yourself go.
Let's say he wants to step through.
Can
you pay attention on the step through
version? I always move and give him room
and he steps. Okay.
Get a good pace. Bend your knees. Be
like a lineman on the NFL line.
Okay. Now, if you
Here, here you are. We're looking down
at this from the base of support. I got
a foot. I got a foot. I have a hand.
Somewhere in there. My line of gravity
touches the ground there. He's got to
get all the way past that. Okay.
I have a lot of strength
because of the legs. They're all there.
I'm perfectly balanced. Remember when we
shifted the line of gravity slightly
behind the heels got really light line
of gravity inside. I can feel I needed
more muscle tension just to move a guy
that's standing with his feet. Now I
give him a three-point stance. Okay.
So let's say he totally overpowers me.
Would it generate a tossy turvy effect.
The only way it could is that he got he
gets my line of gravity way past his
foot. So, let's say he's strong enough
he can overcome that. Just hop forward.
Okay, make him go to the extreme right
when you feel you're going to lead.
Just move forward. Okay, try it again.
Do you need to see that or you
understand it? Okay. Maybe go to the
extreme. Maybe you don't even get to do
this because they can't get enough force
to get you over there. Change your
change your your arms there for good.
There you go.
Why? Why did you take your leg? Why
would you take your face and compromise?
kind of weird
is weird. Stop being weird.
Okay. So we're here
and I have a good base.
That means my spine can be stabilized.
As my spine gets stabilized, my arms get
strong. That's why I want you, Rio, to
tighten up your spine. Okay? That's why
we do compound lifting. So you're going
to think, well, I'm going to I'm going
to turn. Okay? Got it? And you're like,
"Oh, he's he's torquing. He's doing a
shoulder lock on me." Right. So he goes,
"How much energy did I use to none?"
Okay, you got it. So try that one now.
We are strong when we're balanced. We're
weak when we're not balanced. Pull your
arm out.
like pull your arm out like you're
trying to not die. You know what I mean?
Get it back under your control.
[Music]
Hey, you got the idea? All right. So,
why does why why is we able to do all
that? Why am I not pushable? I have too
big a base of support. The line of
gravity has too far to go for how much
penetration he could actually move. So,
I didn't point that out, but
He's down. Just relax.
Okay.
His line of gravity has to fall. It's
somewhere around here. It has to go to
here. Do you see that?
Uh, this. Watch my arms. Watch my hips.
Did I get there? You see that? You see
that? So even then it's like not enough
to get there.
He feels he's losing it. He just shifts
it and
and in all that time that I'm trying to
get where I could never get. Does
everyone understand that I don't I don't
have the material um the architectural
design elements enough to push this part
past that clip.
So but in all that time he can now just
understand okay so all that has to be
addressed in our arts.
So at a minimum, kazushi means not bent
over,
not turning because you can turn and be
balanced rhythmic gymnastics. Okay? Uh
you could bend over and be balanced. Uh
offensive line on the NFL, you see it it
has to mean that the line of gravity is
now outside the base of support.
How far could just be a tiny bit past
the basis point. It'll work. Okay.
To do this, the most efficient way of
doing it, you have a couple ways
you can pull the head. Okay? So, I'm
going to pull the top part of the lever
or push the top part of the lever. You
understand?
and it will eventually get out of the
face of support. That's one way. It's
totally doable. Okay? And we do do it.
We do do it here. So, uh the arm drag,
for example, the arm drag, I pulled you
forward. You kept your face and I just
wanted you to move forward. Okay?
Everyone remember that technique? Okay.
the that's why I pulled on your shoulder
to make you move forward because you
wanted to not fall. That's what that
was. Okay. It's It's not a bad thing.
Uh, another way is
that I directly take the center
and move it out of the basis. Okay? So
as opposed to I move your head until the
line of gravity falls out of the base
support, I take your center and I move
it out of your basic support.
It's more instantaneous that you're now
in position. Okay.
The third way of what we're doing here
is I take your center out of your base
support
as I take your base support in another
direction. You see that? That is the
most efficient way. So
this person
who is being pulled,
they can move their base support back
under and we use that. But we don't do
like sumia to where we kept our feet
still. Remember when we did that discuss
keep your feet still and you let your
line of gravity eventually be pulled
out. When we did the arm drag, we're
like, I'm going to pull on your arm with
the expectation that you're going to try
to stay on balance. Okay,
it is a way. But what we are doing is
this. In this case, you got to look this
way. The center. Let me do it top down.
Here's their feet.
Their line of gravity somewhere around
here going down. The center of gravity
somewhere over here. When I displace,
I'm taking the center moving it out
from the base of support. Okay. Does
that make sense? Okay.
Um
that is when
you now look at his center plot it in a
vertical plane
and here's where it is but I am going to
move it across the map. When we do that
mistake
didn't didn't move yet till now. Dude's
not going to be there in Tinaga. The
opening will be gone by that point.
Okay. My goal is to make this center do
that. Okay. So,
let's say uh let me
do that.
All right. And he can kind of turn
any old way because his center is doing
what? Whatever he's doing. You see?
But if I keep moving his center,
it traveled sagely across the map. You
see that? Okay. That means his line of
gravity went outside his base of
support. When the line of gravity is
outside of base support, the spine is
destabilized and the limbs by which you
attack. No one attacks with the spine.
Okay? It's kind of like in in uh
in law enforcement, we say watch the
hands. Okay? If you shoot me, you got to
use your hands. Okay? No one gets their
tongue and pulls the trigger. Okay? So,
you always got to watch the hands. Watch
the hands. Okay? So, same thing. for you
to hurt me, you're going to have to use
your limbs. But once I destabilize your
base support like this, limbs get super
weak. Okay? That's why our limbs were so
strong in that kite nag because you had
balance, you're spanking, your spine can
be stabilized and you could do whatever
you want as if you're super strong.
That's where that that um that 80 pound
female, the drunk female comes from.
They don't ever have her an actual
condition, okay? They're just pulling on
things and she's moving back underneath
it and she's able to get some strength
in the limbs. Okay? All right. So, when
you're doing this drill,
yes, they they're not going to follow
like tension nugget because there's no
forward inertia. That force is missing
and we're throwing with forces. Okay?
And the centrifugal and centrifugal
energy is not indetecting. But what we
should see is this center got moved
across the map. It shouldn't turn. It
can't turn. It definitely shouldn't go
back to me, right? It can't stay still
either. It has to go whoa like that. And
then what we're going to see is when we
take the center of gravity outside and
the base is deconstructed,
all this gets super light. That's all
our discovery. Just see how light that
gets. Okay, this part. All right. So,
make sure the way to think of it that
center of gravity needs to traverse the
mat. Okay?
Not like that, not across the mat. It
just can't stay here. That was enough.
Okay, try. Good.
Use your arm on their chest.
Don't bring your arm forward. Don't
bring your arm.
You stand here.
Okay.
Here.
See, only move your foot.
Yes.
Go through, not around. Go through, not
around.
Make sure the center's moving.
Yes. Yes. Yes.
Now, Angelo, I'm going to guess that
felt like you didn't do Okay. But
you can see the reaction in Rio. The
panic set in cuz what the Okay.
And that's that's what it needs to feel
like. Okay. What did you do? Right. You
left that foot where it was. You didn't
drag it and turn it out. You made heel
weight. Okay. Try it again. Okay, that
was excellent.
The center moves. Don't get your foot
back there. Leave the center still.
It's a little angled that way. You're
going around the center. Go through his
center.
Yes.
Then watch the heel weight. But that was
this
Watch the heel weight
this way around the center.
Make sure the center moves. Good.
[Music]
Good. Watch the heel.
Two angles,
through around through
good. There we go. See the different
reaction. Okay.
through. Not not allow
better. That's fine.
So,
try to try to grip me on the on the mat
somewhere. Okay. So I know we normally
go
some varian of that
sometimes even you see this one
you're going that way I'm not going
through the center going I'm pulling the
center okay so
let's see if this poetic works okay uh
because I don't want to do that
there's a sense that I'm coming this
way.
This is teni nag on the torso.
Did you see it? Okay.
So maybe that'll help stop going around.
Go slow.
Okay, I'm here.
There's the leg. And go this way.
Okay,
stop trying to go forward because we're
not going to push him the opposite
direction he's going. Okay, try that.
If you're if you're both getting it and
your chem is good on both parties, try
this tension on the torso.
Torso is like I came under his arm.
if you're trying it. If not, keep doing
the drum.
I did I don't want tension on the head
though. Yes.
Better. Yeah.
Yeah. Just place the center. Don't go
around it. Don't go behind. Your foot
goes behind his foot, but your center
doesn't center.
So you got to put that foot where it has
enough penetration to displace it in the
vertical plane. Okay.
Good. Now we got heel weight in. Turn
your toes out.
Come underneath. We're going to go
there. Let's try the torso.
And the more you go through the center,
the the lighter it is.
Okay? Can you see that? Nothing. There's
nothing. I don't feel crap. Okay?
Because as his face goes out, everything
gets lighter on the top. Okay? Where do
I do feel it? I do feel it on the foot.
Okay?
ground. Ground ground. Breathe out.
There's going to be you you brought up
the constant fluctuation. So when you're
putting pressure on him, the reactionary
force is coming. As he's moving, the
reactionary force is cutting at
different angles and you have to keep
adjusting
to keep it on the midoot. Okay? You
can't go now. Oh, that. That
reactionary force I didn't recognize.
Okay? Try again.
Hence task yourself with midfoot
and try and try and try for more through
more and more through last and last this
more and more through. Yeah.
Your foot is the only way you can trip
is if your foot got there first. The
only way your foot can get there first
is you did not sagely disl
Yes.
Back foot.
The only way he could turn out is if
center didn't travel across the space
across the mat instantane.
So what I would do is I would I when I
go to enter
that's your measuring step. Okay. It
says same thing. So, uh, I'll put that
foot maybe I'm measuring. Okay, I know
where his face is right now. So, I got
to figure out where I can get that foot
to go. So, uh, that's I'm going to I'll
dance out of it, right? And then I kind
of make that foot there without showing
the chest pressure. You see? And then I
know from the lean and the step through,
I'm going to take that thing solid.
Okay. So, you have measuring key all the
time. use measuring feet all the time
and that's your measuring foot. So you
put it where it needs to be at the angle
it needs to be in order to displace.
Does that do just like in um the vulcan
work remember the I don't know what the
body's going to be. I don't know what
the footwork's going to be. But if you
let that chest pressure close like that
he got too close. You're not going to do
what you think you need to do. Okay. So
what ended up working was I came back.
We knew I couldn't go forward. And the
caveat was don't step where the form
tells you, step where the situation is
telling you. So same thing here. Okay?
You know what you have to think reverse
like reversely. So I know that this
center has to go at least like that.
Okay?
So if I put this foot here too far out,
can't do it.
Likewise, if I put it here
and I know at the angle that I cut
and I just went ahead and did that.
Now when I go to this angle, my feet are
out. You see that? So you have to put
your foot
not only
at the right measuring the right range
but the right angle of the tap.
Does that make sense? Not not out of
habit. I like there. Okay. All right. I
This is where I always step on this
technique. Okay. No, no, no. The
feeling. Go.
Chase the feeling, not the floor.
And I want more sideways
arm
sideways.
Do that side again.
And I want you to come look over here
for me with your step.
There you go.
Okay.
See his hips, his center came up and it
went forward. There was no pulling back.
The legs went one way. Line of gravity
went the other way. Okay. So, I don't
know what that felt like to you.
I would say maybe it feels like we're
going backwards, but it's not actually
backwards, but it's definitely not at an
angle forward. Okay, to do that, you're
going to go around their center, not
through their center. Okay, try it
again.
Do angle. So, put that foot more
mid foot ground foot.
[Music]
All right. So, you have a couple ways to
do this.
You can just doing this. It's just
But you're going to do it here.
[Music]
You could bring him.
Cool.
You see that? But what you can't do,
you can't go here. He's I There's no way
I'm going to have to take that angle
around. Does that make sense? Okay. So,
try
the back foot. Okay, keep your arch up.
Not
possible, son. Center is moving across
the mat. Not possible.
Don't drag that foot.
[Music]
Two angles.
Lock it up here.
If you unwind your structure, it's very
hard to get it locked.
If you keep your structure,
then I don't have to force it back. You
guys understand that? So, don't
disconnect and then it just keep the the
structure.
Okay, I'm not going here, right? And
then go. Okay, try
hold the
you go. Try hard.
Displace. Attack the center. The arm
will do what it does. Then got to adjust
for the reaction.
Foot was a little out.
Yep.
Good.
All right.
So this is the
bottom part the base displacement of the
X pattern. Okay.
Um
what you do when you do the full X
pattern is the reactionary force. You
saw you you can feel it. Everyone will
feel it. You need that constant
internalization that's happening this
constant fluctuation that Ryan was
talking about earlier. Okay?
and they will do
these last minute tensions. It doesn't
matter who it is. No one likes to go,
"What the fuck?" Okay, everyone's going
to tense.
That tension cannot cause a sympathetic
tension in you because you will stop
fluctuating.
you'll become a lever and then the
reactionary force will cut through any
weaknesses in the scance such as my
fever out. Okay,
but
remember that as they resist
if I can internalize it the adhesion
value goes up because the overall yong
value went up. Does everyone remember
that? Okay. So when we're now in tension
on it, we saw how light it went. Well,
the two start to work on each other. So
as the base goes out, it got light here.
You see? And they will tense
up here. That'll make the base lighter.
And you we're fluctuating this constant
lightness that is going going on.
Um,
we took the top part out, but we're
still you could do it without
any top part because you can use the
inertia that's coming forward to to be
what you are fulcoming around which you
do anyways. But here we didn't really
get the energy going. Okay. But um
when you're even on the body
I if you think about it and how we all
think about tension is it's much easier
to control that head you know and pull
on the distal end of the lever all that
kind of stuff but this other way is as I
weaken your base of support right then
that got light you're going to you're
going to flex on that thank you you're
stuck more than ever. And now the base
and everything starts going to the point
where now they're just here. Okay. And
now gravity is working against them. Not
gravity's working. Okay. Um
and you can do it you could do it
anywhere. So you had some good reps. And
how much arm pressure
are you doing on those good reps where I
go? How?
There's none. There's none. You had some
good reps. There's none. Okay.
Where the technique falls apart is I'm
not on the good foot. That's what
happened. Okay.
How that happened? Multiple ways. I had
wrong foot angle. I uh shuffled into the
wrong foot angle. I um
um did not absorb internalize one of the
reactionary forces and it cut through my
base if I flexed against it. Okay. Um
all those things made me not midfoot
ground. But if I task myself with no
there's a force send back to the same
place. Send it back to the same place.
Send it back to
like we did this morning. Very slow and
very subtly. is just now I hear it at
the speed of light. Okay. And it is it
seems daunting a task because we're
thinking it's an intellectual task and
it's not an intellectual task. So for
example
uh if we watch a baby try to walk
right is a lot of whoa whoa but no one
does that anymore. homeless or drunk or
something, right? No, none of us walk
like that sense of precariousness,
right? So, it's more just I got to get
used to the this gravity,
this inertia and how to always keep it
balanced.
Okay. on that part.
What makes it a little more difficult
than walking, but not really because a
lot of people, you know, like let's say
you get older and you have some bad
falls. Walking can get scary and then
the tension comes in or something like
that. Or maybe you're younger, you had a
terrible crash, right? Something like
that. You slipped on something. So, you
know, Mary tripped on these stairs in
our house and you should see her go down
the stairs now. She can't like a
training floor on the on the stairs.
It's like holding on testing the
friction of the floor. Okay. All that's
happening though is here when we're
fighting is the fear sets in, the
tension sets in. I'm not able to
internalize or stay in the moment.
test. That's okay.
All right. um
that spot that we found at and this kind
of idealized or what would what I say
gaining it.
You have to be able to find it to
technique
where it is different all the time
because the UK does different things all
the time. But conceptually,
designwise, everything is the same.
Because of that, you can do a keynote no
and you could do uh one going backwards
and you could do the shorter versions
where I come in but everything is the
same.
Um,
all right. That's all I got on that.
Questions, comments, observations.
I think maybe this is just part two to
my comment I made earlier about that I
kind of got accommodated to or used to,
you know, our regular training group,
the dojo. And there's this over the
course of this, there's lots of places I
find I have boxes. It's like you're
telling me over and over and over that
I'm leading with the foot and I think
I'm correcting it, but there are things
I'm not checking for. I'm not they're
just not on the table. It's like, oh no,
I have to go back further. I thought I
have to do more to make that not happen
than I was even considering.
Yeah. And um
there's always going to be this ratio
between what's my training environment
and what's the skill that I'm producing.
Okay?
And
currently right now we are in that mid
tier of our edition like that upper
middle tier.
Ron's not here. Taylor's not here. Chris
is not here. We're in that upper middle
tier. Okay.
Um
we're that Why is it the upper middle
tier? Because we're
doing degenerations,
things like that.
And those things are existing not
because you're overtly and consciously
going, "Fuck D." That's that's not
what's happening. What's happening is
those egoic tendencies are coming in and
we're getting fine with them.
And then we're making without anyone
ever saying it. No one ever says it. No
one ever says that deal that I mentioned
earlier today, right? I'll let you see
control, right? I'll let you have power
and then you give me my desires. No one
ever has said that once. Okay?
So, no one says it here, but our Lucas
kind of go ahead and do it.
Does that make sense?
That's where I was mentioning how, you
know, depending on how much sleep Taylor
gets, it seems
he's going to call you on it or how I go
like,
right? Okay. Um, but what's happening
all the other times?
You're like, "Don't throw me. I'll fall
for you." You're like, "Cool. I'll have
to throw you, but I feel like
and you just can't do that. So where
where do I hang on to? This is my
natural inclination as an idea and it is
for human beings is you really got to
stick to the to the metrics that the
teacher is giving. So for example,
you today were slipping that foot and
what's that effect of slipping the foot
that we can't afford or don't want
to go off the center. It's missing this
placement. Yeah, I'm not doing position.
I'm not moving the center. Okay.
Um,
but your teacher says
don't move the foot. The whole body goes
in. The whole center. So, let's say
you're like, I don't I don't know what
that feels like. I don't I don't even
want to do it. You know, my bouquet
doesn't want me to do it. They were
going to fall anyways. But if you just
made like a rule of the teacher said
that their center moves right away, then
eventually you won't rely on the deal if
you task yourself with this commitment.
Okay. Um, so if you pay attention,
every time we take advantage of the UK
who's let me do something,
if your foot still moved first, even
though she went flying, I still yell at
you. You know, you have to do that. You
have to be that, not not my you have to
be my voice. You don't need my voice.
The voice was given one time and now
that's your voice. Okay? So every time
you go and work on this basic, that is
what you're going to do. Every time the
teacher says, "We're not going to 10 or
two, we're going to three." You only go
to three. Even if it doesn't work, you
only go to three. Okay? Because there
you go. If mine counts working, they
fail.
No. working is did you go to three? Does
that make sense? Okay. So, that's the
way around it. Um,
and you know, from the the basketball,
right?
The good shooter just has the same form
all the time. Their mind is in the form,
right? There's going to be times I got
away with it, okay? But that's not
The SOP the SOP is what's good form? I
stick to good form here. Good form is
the teacher said good form. That's what
you said.
So let's say you're like
whatever. Uh I have never found these
people. They don't know what to do. And
all I had to say is stop doing
something. Okay.
But they look just like anyone else
that's just like any suspect on the
street, just like any sparring
situation. Okay? And that's what you
want. And that comes from sticking to
the form
as that's my metric, not did I throw
you. Does that make sense? Okay. Uh
there's just no other way around it. And
this is why it's so important that you
have you have a teacher and that you
don't get rid of the teacher dashi
dynamic.
Is it a pain in the ass? Yes, it
is a pain in the ass. But it's only
because we're contesting it. If we
didn't contest it just like anything
else, it would be
that's what I do. What do you do? I do
what he said.
You going to do what he said? Yeah.
That's scary. And you get all that stuff
that's going right.
Hey, I don't know what to tell you.
Except for if you succumb to fear, you
can't do this.
You're going to contest.
The same thing. If you're if you're too
scared to do what is being told, you
will contest. And now we can't do what
we're supposed to do.
Um what do you do? Release. Surrender.
Release. Accept.
Okay.
Right is what was said. Right is not f.
So on
he fell but he turned the wrong way. I
said that's impossible. You're not
displace.
So he fell but it got checked as wrong.
Why wrong? Because it won't work on him.
You see? Or won't work on the person
that is resisting. It won't work on the
person who has a totally different
culture. Okay? You get it? So I know
that sucks and we're not used to it, but
the more you adopt it, the less it
sucks.
Thank you very much.